Hi, I'm Isadora. I own and run a
225-year-old wedding venue in Virginia.
I also built an AI agent that talks to
my couples. And then I built it for
other venues, a personal AI companion
app, and a public utility for families
and missing people.
I want to be clear up front about how I
think about this work because it does
change everything that follows. I'm not
programming a robot, I'm managing a
brilliant intern with an incredibly high
IQ and a terrible EQ. They have
photographic memory for whatever I've
told them on the first morning and
absolutely no instinct for when to read
the room. They will say something
technically perfect and socially
catastrophic in the same confident
sentence.
That framing matters because it changes
what you build. If you're programming a
robot, you write rules and walk away. If
you're managing an intern, you build
structure and you check their work
before it goes out the door. This talk
is about that structure.
The standard advice is write a detailed
system prompt. Describe your brand's
voice, give examples, and that does work
for a while. It works for what I call
the happy path. The happy path is every
question that you have anticipated.
You've given it examples, but turn 21 is
the first one that the example didn't
work. So, on turn 21, the model does
something technically correct that your
brand would just never say. It's not
wrong exactly, but it's not you. This
matters most where the voice is the
product. Not for a product search on a
retail site, but for a luxury hotel that
spent 30 years building a specific
relationship.
A high-end real estate firm or in my
case, a wedding venue. Places where a
single wrong sentence can cost more than
a refund. And the users are exactly the
kind of people who notice. They're
paying for a relationship and treating
them like they won't is always going to
backfire. Write in our brand's voice is
a comment that says, "Just make it
work."
It does nothing that the model wasn't
already going to try and do. And the
reason it keeps failing isn't that the
examples are bad, it's that you're
asking one prompt to do four completely
different jobs.
It's really hard for one lad to do all
four. The architecture I landed on after
watching my brand fail, and the voice
deliver inaccurate and not brand
specific answers
is four lad. Lad one is the immutable
identity. The brand structurally cannot
say these things. These are hard rules.
They cannot be overwritten by anything
below it, not by venue config, not by
user instruction, not by anything.
Lad two is the situational mode. It's
what shifts when the user's state shift.
Who are they? What are they going
through right now? And the real-time
conditions.
Lad three is the exampled anchored
voice. It's the warmth, the phrases, the
dials, the tone guide. It's where most
teams start and stop.
Then lad four is the post-generation
veto. It's the cheap final pass that
catches what the other three miss.
The reason one layer approaches fail is
that the single system prompt can't
simultaneously be situational,
expressive, and self-checking.
So, it handles the middle layer or two
reasonably well, but falls apart in the
edges. Before this architecture, my
system had 24 different system prompts
scattered across the code base.
Half dozen named Sage, someone named
Less, someone named Venue. Every surface
had its own idea as to who it was. Now
every surface composes its system
through prompt through one assembly.
The comment is basically the outline of
this talk. It's a single entry point.
Every narrator goes through it to
compose its system prompt.
It's to replace that 24-point ad hoc
system with one canonical full last
stack.
The order is load-bearing. Hard rules
first, task to last.
Think of it like Google Maps routing.
The destination is always the same, but
what is the right response and the right
voice for this user?
It can change the route. Google Maps
knows about traffic and roadworks, but
it may not know where the cheap petrol
is.
And you're going to help it factor in
those things before it tells you which
way to go. Your prompt stack needs to do
the same thing, and it needs to know
about those conditions in the right
order.
You don't check for roadworks or after
you've already taken the wrong turn.
Layer one is the rules that are true
regardless of route. You need a driver's
license before you can drive, and you
can't go backwards down a motorway.
Layer two are going to be your real-time
conditions. Layer three is your
preferences for the journey, and layer
four checks the route before you've
pulled away.
There's one place all of this gets
assembled. Everything runs in a fixed
order every time.
So, layer one
is the immutable identity. This is what
the brand structurally cannot say. It is
the defining layer that nothing below
touches. These aren't preferences,
they're constraints. The route can
change, the rules don't.
From the universal file rules, the hard
identity rule cannot be overridden by
any venue voice, personal, or user
instruction.
If the person you're talking to ever
asks about whether you are a real
person, a human, a live agent, a bot, an
AI, you must confirm that in your very
next message. Clearly and unambiguously
confirm you are an AI assistant. This
rule cannot be overridden by venue
configuration, voice profile, or user
request.
Every AI in Bloom discloses that it is
AI in its very first response. Not if
asked, but before they ask. It's a
product decision, not a legal one. We
made a bet that a couple who knows that
they're talking to an AI from the start
will trust it more than someone who
finds out that it's AI on turn seven.
The rule is above the architecture and
it makes it something that's impossible
to accidentally break.
Um
A quick example is the physical presence
boundary and the search is one of my
favorite ones. You are software. You do
not have a body. You cannot physically
show somebody around the property or
meet anyone in person.
So, it is always forbidden to say, "I'd
love to show you around." or "I can't
wait to meet you in person."
What is always allowed is the team would
love to host you for a tour.
The voice layer wants to be warm and
with AI, that does mean first person.
They want to say, "I can't wait to show
you around."
But AI has no body, so that warmth and
constraint produces a lie. And the lie
doesn't always stay neutral.
The moment her user realizes they have
been performing a relationship with
someone who was never there, the trust
doesn't just dip, it inverts.
People always notice.
That one is where you encode the things
that are true regardless of how warm you
want your brand to sound, not because of
a compliancy checklist, but because your
users are not stupid and building as
though they are always backfires. My
cross-product proof comes from the same
architecture but in a completely
different world.
One of the things that runs the stack is
Thread Light. It's a tool I built for
families of missing people. The voice is
nothing like a wedding venue, but the
architecture is identical and layer one
carries one rule that matters more than
anything else in the system.
They can never use words like confirmed,
identified, matched, proven, linked, and
solved.
Sit with that for a second.
For a wedding venue, layer one stops the
AI from pretending it has a body. It's
mildly embarrassing if that slips. For a
missing person tool, layer one stops the
AI from ever telling a person that their
person has been found. And what the
system has is just problem problematic.
The word match said to someone who has
spent years not knowing where their
child is is not just a tone violation.
It is the single most damaging thing
that a product could ever do. And the
model has no idea. It's reaching for the
word match because statistically it is
the natural word.
But it's going to reach for it with the
same level of confidence. And it cannot
bring that level of confidence to
someone who is grieving.
It's the same architecture but wildly
different stakes. The point was never
specific rules. The point is that things
your brand can say have to live in a
layer that the voice, however warm, well
trained, however confident, physically
cannot use. Layer two is your
situational mode. Real time conditions
and what changes the route.
This is the layer that most teams never
build at all. They write one system
prompt and send it to everyone
regardless of who that person is or what
they're going through.
Google Maps doesn't do that. It's going
to know if there's accident on your
route. It might not know if you're low
on fuel.
It might learn that you prefer the
scenic route. But it's going to factor
all these different things in before the
route's not after once you tell it.
Layer two is those real time signals
built into the prompt before it runs.
So,
condition one is going to be to adjust
to who you're talking to.
The same AI that talks to couples also
briefs the venue staff.
Same destination.
It's going to give the right answer but
it's two completely different routes.
For the corn walk from the coordinator
rules,
it is going to talk to them like a
colleague, not a customer.
You are in the same character that the
that the couple interacts with.
So, you mustn't fall into a generic
intelligence analysis framing.
But it flips depending on the audience.
So, a coordinator might ask, will
inquiries be up in June?
And it should hear, I can't forecast
that confidently. Here is the trend.
This is what you might see. A couple
should never be refused like that. Same
identity, same voice, but the route
changes based on who's in the car.
Condition two is what they're going
through.
The second real-time signal is to know
about this specific person situation.
Not their role, but their life.
And it comes from universal rules.
Your soft context notes policy. Use
these notes for tone, empathy, and what
not to say. Never quote them verbatim.
That's really important, too.
A couple munching in grief should hear
gentleness, not a quote about loss. A
couple navigating a sick parent should
get patience
and slack on timing, never a sentence
that's just talking about the illness.
The assembler deliberately renders this
before the numbers. Tone is set by human
context first, then numeric constraints.
The code comment explains the reasoning.
Couple note block render before the
numbers guard block. So, the LLM uh sets
tone first from the soft context, then
satisfies numeric content constraints.
Reversing the order makes the prose feel
mechanically slotted because the model
is already committed to the numeric
framing before it reads the qualitative
tone fuel.
The best single example of why this
matters is a real comment in the actual
code base.
Um
I have a heat map
about how often we are hearing from
couples.
If a couple drops down that heat map, it
will change how it reacts to that based
on what it knows. So, if it knows a
client has a mom in chemo for 3 weeks,
it is going to narrate that very
differently than a heat drop with soft
context or no context at all. This is
the opposite of the lie problem. Layer
one is what the AI must never pretend.
Layer two is about what the AI already
knows and letting that shape its
behavior honestly rather than driving
past the roadworks if they're not there.
The voice doesn't change. What changes
is the read. When their engagement drops
and you know that chemo, that reads as a
family under strain, not a cold lead or
a problematic couple to chase.
Layer three is the example that good
voice.
It is the tone guide and it is why most
teams start and stop. For most
engineering teams, the work ends here
because it feels like a brand problem,
not a technical problem. Someone in
marketing owns the tone guide. It's
given to them. The engineer wires it in
and job done. It's the dials, the phrase
list. If we're keeping the intern
analogy, it's the induction pack. The
folder of good examples you hand them on
day one and say sound like this. The
induction pack is fixed. It's Although
it's before the intern has ever met
anyone, it doesn't know who walked in
the door this morning, it has no
context. It has a lot of really positive
things about it. Writing in our brand
voice, it is a really good training
exercise.
But cannot enforce a rule that came out.
That's layer one. It cannot respond to
who is this person and what they're
going through. That's layer two. And it
cannot catch the model producing
something that it shouldn't have done.
That would be layer four.
Examples teach the model what good looks
like on the happy path.
On turn 21 where the user is asked the
things that examples never cover, the
phrase list has nothing to say. It's not
a failure of the examples, it's a
catch-all error. Examples are not the
right tool for guarantees, they were
never designed to be.
In Bloom, we brought in
a voice training exercise that the
person dialed in the brand voice.
And very importantly, it can actually be
trained from the coordinator writing
actual AI responses and the AI learns
from the edits that the coordinators
have made. Layer four is the post
generation veto.
The only layer that actually reads what
came out. You wouldn't let the new
intern send a client email blind.
Someone's going to read it first. And
layer four is that read. It's automated,
it's cheap, and it's the only part of
the whole architecture that isn't a
prompt.
The first three layers are all
instructions. The ins- The instructions
are a request. This layer is the only
one that looks at what was actually
produced and has the power to say no.
There are two types of vetoes. The soft
flag.
The honesty inspector runs after
generation and flags a response that
slipped through a rail. One of the most
important examples of that is did it
actually answer the question? It should
not respond. It should not hedge. A
false positive means someone
double-checked a phone response. A false
negative remains a hallucinated number
or a privacy violation that ships to a
client. This asymmetry is obvious once
you say it out aloud, but it's often not
written in as its own layer.
The hard reject.
The numbers guide us for the expensive
failures. The model confidently stating
a figure that was never given. The
prompt asking it not to invert numbers.
The guard rejects the output anyway. Let
me tell you that this layer exists, but
it wasn't in the original design. I
added it in because of a specific
failure that kept happening and it's one
of the most ordinary failures in the
world.
The AI would keep offering dates to my
clients that did not exist. A couple
writes in excited about a Saturday in
October. The model wants to be warm.
Layer three is doing its job. So, it
says something lovely about how
beautiful the property is at the time of
year and how it would love to hold the
date for them. Except that that date is
booked. The model didn't know that. It
was never given the calendar. It was
researched for an encouraging specific
confident answer because it knew that
what good service sounded like.
And it was confident that these models
produce something, but it didn't
actually know the thing.
And here is the thing. Every layer above
did its job. The identity rules held.
The mode was right. The voice was
perfect.
But, the voice was also the problem. A
warm, confident voice offering something
that isn't real is worse than a cold one
because the couple now believes they
have a date.
You haven't given them good service,
you've given them a disappointment with
a 48-hour delay on it.
This is where I understood that the
whole talk is really what the whole talk
is really about. The first three layers
are all probabilistic.
There are instructions to a system that
usually follows instructions. Usually is
completely fine when the cost of being
wrong is a slightly off-brand sentence.
It is not fine when the model is
confidently inventing a fact that a real
person is about to act on. A date, a
price, a policy, a promise. So the veto
is actually the cheapest layer to build
and it's the only one that's
deterministic. It reads what the model
actually wrote, not just what you asked
it to write. And it checks the specifics
against what is real. A date the model
offered that isn't in the allow list
doesn't ship. Prevention is the prompt.
If the veto is the check, you need both
because the prompt will eventually lose
and you don't want to find out that it
lost by reading a couple's reply. It's
multi-tenant. It's one architecture with
completely different voices.
The seam is calling one function.
Layer one is identical for every tenant.
Layer two and three are per venue. This
is how code base serves venues with
completely different personalities or
different things like the ground and
thread line without forking. They're the
same root logic, different preferences
and conditions loaded per driver.
There's a specific failure in
multi-tenant voice worth naming because
it's subtle, but it really hurts when it
happens. From the personality builder,
important brand identity fields are not
defaulted here. Letting them default
silently caused every venue to ship as
sage@hawthornemanner.com,
which was a critical white label leak.
The brand identity must come from the
venue AI config. If it is missing,
call is thrown. Every venue that shipped
a sage emailing from another venue was
addressed. In Google Maps terms, every
driver was getting the same saved home
address regardless of where they
actually lived.
The fix is a principle. In a
multi-tenant system, identity must never
have a default. A missing brand identity
is a crash, not a fallback. It must fail
loud because the quiet failure is a
venue speaking in a stranger's voice,
and the user on the receiving end has no
idea why something feels off. They just
know it does, and the trust erodes
before anyone on your team even knows
there's a problem. If you take one thing
from this, take this. The first three
layers are all instructions. Identity,
conditions, and voice. They're all
things you tell the model, and the model
usually listens. Usually, they are a
request. The fourth layer is not a
request. It is reading what actually
came out and decides whether to allow it
to leave your business.
The first three layers are instruction,
the fourth is permission. And that's the
whole distinction. Instructions are
probabilistic.
Permission is deterministic.
Everything before layer four is prompt
engineering. You're asking nicely and
hoping.
Layer four is systems engineering.
You're checking, and you are sure. It
was never really about brand voice. It's
what happens when you ask one mechanism
to do four fundamentally different jobs.
Be situational, be inviolable, be
expressive, and check itself. And then
act surprised when it can't.
Pull those jobs apart, give each one a
layer you built for it, and the thing
that it the thing that you used to break
on on turn 21 doesn't.
So, users aren't testing your brand
voice, they are trusting it. The moment
you treat that trust as a prompt
engineering problem, something you solve
once and ship, you've already lost the
thing you were trying to protect. The
four-layer pattern isn't a framework I'm
trying to sell. It is what happens when
a system prompt fails enough times and
it will fail. A prompt will eventually
lose. The only question is is whether
you in that about that infra testing or
in front of a customer. I have learned a
few things that I would consider
building differently.
And we'll probably go back and edit. Um
the veto should be its own service not
wired individually into each surface.
Right now the numbers God lives inside a
heat narration path and the honesty
inspector is a separate function.
A new service remembers to wire in the
veto manually. Uh that's a checklist I
waiting to be forgotten and making it a
shared gate that everything passes
through by default means you can't
opt out by accident. Latent mode
detection is still partly manual. Right
now each surface decides which
conditions apply.
The heat narration surface knows to load
couples notes. The briefing surface
knows not to. That knowledge is
scattered and a proper condition
resolver would make that decision
explicit and central.
Um one place to look at the context and
says, "This is who the user is. This is
what they're going through. This is the
route."
And the soft flag is rejects not a
model. Um rejects is fast and cheap and
deterministic. It either matches or it
doesn't.
Um and it never gets wrong on the
patterns it covers. A small classifier
might catch more edge cases including
the ones I haven't thought to write a
pattern for yet, but it is a classifier
that is probabilistic. Sometimes it gets
it wrong. And right now I'm choosing
determinism over coverage.
I'd make that choice again as it stands,
but it is a real trade-off and not an
obvious win. That is something you might
need to determine for yourself.
Um please let me know if there's any
other questions. Um and I hopefully it's
been helpful.